[Musique]
bonjour à la réunion bonjour le monde
comment ils les autres tout
alors aujourd'hui on est à la plaine des
palmistes
j'ai édité jean-paul alors l'endroit
s'appelle le clos des mimosas
c'est poétique comme un poème d'amour
alors ils font chambres table d'hôte et
paraît qu'il ya un petit carré qui se
prépare pour ce midi un mois je vous en
dis pas plus on verra ça tout à l'heure
et venez venez venez me viens viens
[Musique]
cette annonce si vous n'appréciez pas
mon moment bonjour bonjour comment il
est très bien merci d'accueillir nos
dents dans un autre temps autres
chambres d'hôtes et table d'hôtes
alors me vois que j'ai super bien
protégé là avec une bébête petite chaîne
de montagnes alors diamant un petit peu
où ça nous les
en bref alors où c'est que nous sommes à
la plaine des palmistes deuxième village
chemin de la petite plaine dans un
environnement très calme et puis ben
propice pour l'accueil des clients par
c'est parfait c'est parfait 1
on est bien là 1 ça commence bien les
missions 1 alors banal à diamant comme
ça que je ne pourrais pas un petit car
guy mony et d'infos le coup notamment au
ces il est tout ça ok pas de problème ne
venait s'évadant tard et enfin nous en
sommes en fait
[Musique]
nous faisons de la grosse cuisine au feu
de bois sur ce foyer
les préparations
c'est dans la cuisine en fait on prépare
devant les clients d'accord et là pour
le coup les épices ou des films couper
la wii darcos et diament juge pour faire
baver un petit peu oui
quelques la 19e pas pour nous va a lancé
un carré de canard et
[Musique]
nous allons réactiver le feu
on a l'impression de monsieur jean paul
me vois pas trop ça lui les malins c'est
son travail
eh ben tu sais quoi hésite oui bah pour
la peine tout à l'heure c'est lui qui va
faire l'interview voilà parce que moi
j'aime pas quand les gens se cachent
comme saison timide à bastien ah bah
quand on parle du loup jean paul bien
fait pour un petit peu le fun ou là mais
bon c'est sûr
[Musique]
jean-paul ces spécialistes du feu
fireman on l'appelle et je vous dois à
vendre il joue avec spiderman et joue
avec lucie fireman on en a à la réunion
c'est jean-paul et la plaine des
palmistes les jo d'hiver ça aide
[Musique]
le canard déjà découpé sa monnaie dont
tout ça avec qui vous achetez la matière
première ça veut dire qu'aucun à la fin
et c'est alors ben on achète chez
monsieur turpin qui est un agriculteur
et qui il a une tuerie c'est pour ça
qu'on achète avec lui à la plaine des
palmistes un corps parfait tout ce qui
est légumes
et caetera à demain un petit terrain
pour planter ici ou comment ça se passe
non alors nous avons une exploitation
qui est sur saint joseph
donc nous faisons de la can
principalement mais avec une
diversification notamment les légumes on
prend les légumes du moment c'est à dire
là on va faire une job de
papaye ça va être les papayes de de
l'expo voilà les exploitations savait
déjà mais nous en avait deux trois
spécimens sur le terrain j'en dis pas
plus notamment un petit coup ces fameux
spécimens mâles va écouter là pour le
moment on a qu une citrouille 1 c'est la
plus petite en tout cas sa citrouille
laine et en plus cela veut dire man
avait un avis combien de kilos ça sent
qu'il joue à 100 kg mon garçon à 14 ans
les plus maigres
c'est impressionnant
de l'homme et puis tiens bon tiens bon
pour elle
et c'est moi qui ait l'honneur de
commencer la cuisson du duc harricana a
laissé baracci l'attention pas trop bon
et drummond jeu il saute et comme on dit
souvent et je répèterai jamais assez
faites bien votre carry les enfants
c'est tout c'est ça le secret d'un bon
cari alors jean paul mais voit que les
épiceries t elle à huy corps alors dire
un petit peu c'est quoi la matière l'a
alors là c'est un jeu là on prépare
toujours un petit peu avant ce sont les
oignons les épices de live avec le teint
avec les aromates et les petites tomates
fraîches à côté on va mettre d'abord
quand là bas ce sera bien prix 11 bien
rouge vient bien coloré on va mettre les
oignons une fois qu'elle sera les
oignons commencerait à roussir un tout
petit peu prendre de la couleur
on va mettre des delahaye l'appareil on
va tourner et tourner c'est toujours une
question de tourner et à la fin on va
mettre de la tomate
on va faire roussir la tomate également
avec et en dernier on va rajouter une
pointe de curcuma le curcuma c'est très
très bon pour la santé
alors donné la couleur oignons une fois
que la viande est bien rouge bien aussi
oignons pareil aussi un petit peu
l'aïe tomate est un petit peu et que tu
m'as et tout ça dans l'ordre mais bon
absolument mais mérite mon diplôme j'ai
aller ou absolue mais bon tu peux un
super âge et vos diplômes de carrie
canon
bateau
thiago silva
beaucoup rêvent
alors
m
quarto
alors voilà donc mais devant le devant
devant chez toi devant gilles la table
d'hôtes tu vois moi quand je vois le
petit centre pis on dit comme ça on a
envie de crue de d'en parler dans la
petite maison dans la prairie
les jolies sérieux les super naturel
mais trouve ça super jolie en même temps
ça serait vraiment dommage d'enlever
d'enlever d'enlever tout ça et n'écrase
pas les fleurs aussi thouars
attention enfin qu' un petit endroit de
zénitude oui je t'emmène voir alésia
grâce à la surface de la montagne quand
les gens viennent là ils viennent pour
se reposer en général mais il met pour
un soin moi j'ai famille toi justement
parce que je veux profiter de la nature
à 100% naturel et puis va avait
là-dedans
avec ça en face ah ouais ah oui
oui je peux rester un petit rally soleil
je peux rester dix minutes ce soir là
juste dix minutes n'ont pas le droit
c'est un ampli alors est-ce que tu
reçois beaucoup de touristes et des
réunionnais comment ça se passe qu'est
ce qu'ils viennent rechercher aussi les
gens recherchent plutôt le calme
d'accord vient le chercher sérénité le
calme
donc tu as des locaux j'ai dénombré gd
et beaucoup de gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur l'extérieur les suisses des
allemands et
oui ça c'est réservé par internet dans
le monde réservé par internet
ils viennent ils restent à ce jour deux
parfois deux trois jours pourquoi il
sung nous seuls lui et moi j'ai envie de
rentrer là-dedans morts
[Musique]
hé hé
on
alors la table est mise elle est miss
jolie quand même on va revenir un petit
peu sur ce qu'il ya dessus donc le cari
canard il est là le jolie carrie cana
avec that is empalot de à moi me sens
mais pédiatres les mots me sens déjà les
bons donc la dope de pas paris achard et
le poids le gros poids qui était en
train de cuver tout à leurs côtés du
canard zesa voilà ben moi en tout cas
comment dire ça pas trop trop envie de
tardez pas c'est l'enjeu de sérieuses
oui je crois que c'est le moment là tu
tues tu as envie de manger aux sites
wallons 1
eh ben on se permet sur un petit monde
tout petits morceaux comme ça les
origines en fait tu as dit les rues si
c'est pour ça
sitôt régime
[Musique]
alors jean paul lasne ou les au milieu
de notre jardin
tu me disais qu'il y avait des gens qui
faisaient face du tai-chi ici lui
attribue de temps en temps raconte moi
un petit peu le pourquoi du comment de
l'histoire s'il te plaît c'est une
longue histoire c'est une longue
histoire on y va comme tous les ans
comme je pense que tu comme tous les les
réunionnais tous les gens qui vivent
dans les îles les réunionnais arriver à
cette année on a un certain âge on est
obligé de quitter l'île de la réunion
pour pour et d'une trouver du travail ou
se perfectionner dans son dos un domaine
bien particulier nous ça a été le
l'hôtellerie et la restauration
il arrive à certains moments on a envie
de rentrer chez nous quoi et en fin de
compte on l'avait trouvé la maison là et
de cette maison a grandi on a fait la
grande salle où le sud dans tout à
l'heure ça c'était à 97,97 quand on a
ouvert 98 on a ouvert
c'était un restaurant et ensuite on l'a
on l'a on a arrêté la restauration on a
fait des chambres et on a mis des
chambres plus la restauration comme ça
on travaille en couple écoute je crois
qu'on a fait le tour
oui un mois ba écoute franchement j'ai
passé un très bon moment avec vous mais
moi aussi un moment partagé le mans
j'étais bien bon allemand j'étais bien
bourrin il est content quand il est
comme ça là ça veut dire qu'il est
content d'accord c'est comme ça où il
allait il va pouvoir rentrer dans le
battre empilement l' écoute je vais te
laisser en espérant entrevoir bien toi
parce que moi je vais revenir merci à
toi d'accord tu passe le bonjour à tata
madame edith met d'accord tu veux
remercier beaucoup et à la prochaine
bien que tous les bons l'on retrouve
[Musique]
tiens
après un bon repas au creux des mimosas
s'est arrêtée au piton des songes sur le
sentier botanique c'est juste magnifique
beaucoup de paix de bois endémique alors
bien sûr dans les alentours tu as la
forêt de bébour la forêt de bélouve des
endroits au pique-niqué et là moi
personnellement mais je ne suis pas du
tout sorti de l'auberge mais alors pas
du tout avec mon gros ventre plein aïe
aïe aïe
[Musique]